[Music]
I just want to point out how creatively
you or your time's up button actually
has a little thread sewing it oh no none
so it doesn't go anywhere it's very
important and also important that you've
come to become known for a cuss word or
two a cuss word or two I know what are
you doing thank you I appreciate that
thank you there might be of you tonight
baby you're currently shooting hands
mate tail right now right so you snuck
out any previews you can give us are you
really gonna so everybody can see their
name you can take a freeze-frame and
then see the name make them feel really
yeah that would be I'm not allowed to do
when you make a permanent if you it yeah
okay we're gonna hold you to it
okay invite us to the tattoo session
that's really good maybe you can feel me
hey you know big little lies has got
Meryl Streep coming on
any person that you would go crazy to
have on hands may tell meryl streep can
come by anytime she wants he'll always
be a spot for her earrings one of my
favorites you know you played a woman in
the 50s trying to work her way through
the corporate ladder now looking at how
Hollywood is changing how it is
happening here what does it mean to you
what do you think we still don't have
equal pay which she fought for in 1960
you know I think she would be very very
surprised but I'm glad that something's
happening at least is a little late
[Music]